I know this person better than I know
myself I know her better than she knows
me knowing her know each other for about
a year and a half we spend 40 hours
minimum a week together or we're
together a hundred percent of the time
all the time every day 24/7 this is
gonna tear apart a relationship
I know ever with like new people it'll
be like hi mike phirman how you doing
all right if it's our friends it's like
this
she starts off in physics very like me
ah you enjoy having her hurt your hands
out like this
what like okay guys so what I usually do
like that is yeah she does like almost
like a baby character where she'll be
like I'm Kelsey Darragh and I have
everything and then she's like but I'm
not a comedian of that bad I'm just
really stressed out right now I've got
like 20 videos to do and the white
supremacy is still holding me back you
know we didn't we didn't we didn't get
that answer to that question we asked
did we mmm
no we didn't can you believe that this
person wrote that I mean I follow them
on Twitter and they didn't follow me
back should either be shouting at you
were talking we're like she's pretending
to listen but she's not she's on her
phone so I could be like I'm went to
space today and she'd be like yeah yeah
of course yeah Kelsey gets very
aggressive you don't understand what
this has caused you dinner and she like
points and her four fingers are like oh
when I see you stressed out like you
still smile just like in a really shady
ass way like like so when you're
fighting with Gabby
instead of being her normal voice turret
self she shuts down to make you feel
very guilty and it was sort of like
looks at the floor well I guess I just
didn't I didn't expect this to happen
today you're like an old southern lady
you're like what you did last night was
totally fine by me but that's none of my
business
bless her heart I am so sick of it I
just over it I mean where it's dead you
up his hair literally stands up when
he's dressed up if I criticize like
something that's like that's like in
left-field she'll be like okay so I'm a
bad person
it becomes a very personal like why do
you hate me other than hate
that's like nobody hates you we does
drink Batman Gavi hates admitting that
she's drunk
and I think she's so worried about
losing control that she I you become
boring mmm
Kathy I can't I can't golly and it's
always like you're like shucks for
everyone on me no I got this don't be
ridiculous
Alison becomes the best person I've ever
met she just like everybody's best
friend hey how you doing she's so funny
you can't leave me don't leave me you
can't leave me don't leave me are you
leaving you can't leave me I love you
don't leave me she'll be sitting down
and we're having a nice dinner she's I'm
just gonna have a couple glasses of wine
girl it's gonna be fine wine after
Winant is that I love you I love life
I'm doing so good and literally she'll
put her head down she'll be like oh my
god everything's great she guess it's a
big target I'm ready I'm gonna kill
someone
last person party here it's like Vic
she's doing a lot of dis you enjoy like
grabbing like like right here by the
handle out like that yes for someone
who's like so confident in their body
and like sexually expressive no move
that's like an old person out of pocket
just like cause like doing this thing
he's like and he like looks down and
does this like tingly like this like
really really intense and she won't let
go for the whole song he says that yeah
one time she was doing this to a fifth
harmony song and then she just went if
you don't commit what are you doing it's
fun to like know for other people what
you do I guess I never would have
realized that that's how I fight until
you pointed out to me whatever I like
the way you do your weird [ __ ] because
that's what makes you